you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
scientists say they've created the
whitest ever paint
which could help cool buildings and
tackle the climate crisis
more smiles than substance we've got the
latest from brussels
on a virtual meeting between the chinese
french and german leaders
all about climate change and saving the
octopus teacher
kelp forests one of the world's richest
ecosystems
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us but also
show you
just how far we've come coming up more
on what we learned from today's meeting
between leaders from china
france and germany on climate issues but
first
scientists have developed what they
claim is the whitest ever paint
as a way of tackling global warming
engineers at purdue university in
indiana
say it could be used on the roofs of
buildings as a way of cooling them
reducing the need for air conditioning
well in a moment i'll be speaking to one
of the professors behind it but first
here's why it's important and how it
could make a difference
[Music]
it's it is better than current white
paint because it's reflecting
a lot more than conventional white paint
does
and as a result of it reflecting a lot
more a lot less heat is entering the
building
and therefore the demand for cooling
that building
is significantly reduced
[Music]
when white paint was put on the top of
this hospital the
patients who suffered from extreme heat
particularly on the top floor of that
hospital
were dramatically benefited so some
studies recommend
that using smart surfaces across cities
can reduce
their global warming impact by 10 to 15
percent and
reduce temperatures by about five degree
fahrenheit by mid-century
well joining me now from indiana is
professor shulin ruan one of the
engineers who developed the paint
welcome to you so how can an ultra white
paint
help tackle global warming so the
commercial
pain available on the market today they
only reflect
80 to 90 percent of sunlight which means
they absorb 10 to 20 percent sunlight
uh so different er pain we reflect
as high as 98.1 percent of sunlight back
to the space
so it only absorbs 1.9 percent of
sunlight
that's kind of a cutting the absorption
of p from the sun by 5 to 10 times so uh
you know that kind of really helps stop
the warming trend of the earth
and so how much whiter is this paint
than the current
current whitish shade and how much
difference do you think that will
actually make
our paint is you know looks much wider
than the other
commercial white paints available now
compared to the
commercial paint that reflects to about
80 percent
uh if you cover our paint on a house
with a 100
square meter floor size it can help
um you know uh reduce almost 20 kilo
20 kilowatt of the heating from the sun
so that's really
you know a big deal in some areas using
our paint on the roof can even totally
remove the need to turn on the air
conditioner how widely would you expect
modern buildings to use this how widely
used could it be
actually we already got a lot of
inquiries from the hot climates over the
world
such as india middle east africa
south america central america and then
south part of the united states
people already like painting their
houses with white
but again our white is much wider than
those they can purchase so hopefully
our paint can be available uh you know
uh
you know a year or two so people can use
it
now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and
scientists are warning that coral reefs
around hawaii
could be destroyed by heavy flooding
when storms occur
sediment is washed into the ocean and
onto the reefs
it blocks sunlight from hitting the
reefs making it harder for the coral to
get nutrients through
photosynthesis hawaii's state
climatologist says extreme rainfall will
become more common on the islands
as a result of global warming
a new hybrid of bear has been discovered
which could be more resilient
to climate change grizzly bears have
been mating with endangered polar bears
to create the so-called
pisley bear which experts say is better
adapted to warm weather
grizzly bears in alaska and canada have
been migrating north
as temperatures increase bringing them
into close contact with polar bears
and winemakers in france are hitting the
bottle after a difficult start to the
growing season
it's estimated at least a third of
french wines worth
almost 2 billion euros in sales will be
most lost this year due to unseasonably
cold temperatures in spring
government ministers say the extreme
weather is the result of climate change
now it's been a big week in climate
diplomacy so let's remind you of what's
been going on
and u.s climate envoy john kerry has
arrived in south korea
after several days of talks with
officials in china
meanwhile china's president xi jinping
has taken part in
a virtual climate change meeting with
the german chancellor angela merkel and
the french president
emmanuel macron well later today
president biden will host japan's prime
minister at the white house with issues
on climate change thought to be high on
the agenda
and the u.s president has invited world
leaders to a virtual earth day summit
next thursday russia and china have both
yet to confirm
if they're going to attend well there
were some positive
messages today following that meeting
between chinese french and german
leaders
so joining me now from brussels is our
correspondent michelle clifford so
michelle what did we learn from this
meeting today
well it was certainly very important to
get uh the chinese president uh on board
china is the world's biggest polluter
in terms of co2 emissions so angela
merkel
and president uh macron were very
pleased to have
uh president xi in the conversation what
we're being told
is that he reaffirmed china's goal of
co2
neutrality by 2060. that's a
a big deal in terms of a commitment and
he also decided to
sign up to what's known as the montreal
uh protocol kigali amendment to
strengthen
control of greenhouse gases
and the french and the germans said that
they were very pleased about that
uh indeed so um president xi uh
committed to working uh further with
germany and france and other
eu nations in terms of um issues of
climate change and of course the eu
at the moment has made very ambitious uh
climate uh
goals uh of its own committing to
reducing
greenhouse gas emissions uh by at least
55 percent by 2030
and aiming for climate neutrality uh by
2050 anna
thanks michelle the bafta award-winning
netflix documentary my octopus teacher
has become a cult hit
taking viewers into a world few have
ever seen
it focuses on filmmaker craig foster and
the wild octopus he follows for most of
her life
it's filmed in a kelp forest off the
coast of cape town in south africa
and now a campaign has been launched to
preserve the underwater ecosystem that's
under threat
as the world's oceans warm well earlier
i spoke to pippa erlich who directed the
documentary
and started by asking her about the
importance of kelp forests
[Applause]
hellfires are important because they are
very important carbons to
sequesters they provide habitat
to a very very rich uh
level of biodiversity and an incredible
community of species
they're also very productive ecosystems
and another thing that we're realizing
especially in the age of rising sea
levels is that kelp forests protect our
coastlines from storms and swells
but they're very vulnerable the ipcc
report which came out a couple of years
ago listed kelp forests as the second
most
vulnerable eco systems marine ecosystems
to climate change
and they're just beautiful magical
places you go
underwater in that kelp forest and it
feels like you're in
a wonderland and you put this
extraordinary relationship between craig
foster and the octopus at the heart of
your film it's quite
an emotional relationship was that a
deliberate decision
as soon as we saw the footage and we
heard how craig
described his experience the nature of
the story is that it's an emotional one
um it it it wasn't really deliberate it
was just
the story that we had in front of us and
we
we were very lucky to have something
that you know
could move people how do you move on
from such an
intense experience like that being able
to work on a film like this and with a
story like this
is truly a once in a lifetime experience
i work with the sea change project which
is the organization that
that craig co-founded almost 10 years
ago
and what we're trying to do is raise
awareness around kelp forests all over
the world
and specifically protect the great
african sea forest which is the far
the kelp forest where the octopus lived
and we have a lot of work to do and
we're starting with a big
local screening campaign later this year
and we've got a lot of other
exciting projects in the works the day
after the form launched we were getting
an email every three seconds and that
went on for weeks
we've received emails from psychologists
telling us that they're recommending
their film to their clients we've
received emails from young marine
biologists who
you know were really disillusioned in
the time of covert
about the careers that they were
starting out in and have decided to
carry on because they found the form
inspiring so
as a filmmaker and a storyteller to get
that kind of reaction to your work
is the most fulfilling thing that that
can happen the philippines is one of the
countries most at risk from the climate
crisis
because of sea level rises extreme
weather events
rising temperatures and severe rainfall
in the latest of our series of climate
diaries
youth activists mitzi janelle tan tells
us how her personal experiences of the
climate emergency
led to her campaigning to raise
awareness of climate issues
both in the philippines and around the
world
i grew up seeing the impacts of climate
change firsthand
having to be afraid of drowning in my
own bedroom
and sometimes waking up in the middle of
the night with flood water in my room
and having to scoop it out
cold and dark and afraid
growing up i would go to strangers and
talk to them about
greenhouse gas emissions and global
warming in the ozone layer
because climate education in the
philippines is
so lacking i didn't even make the
connection between the typhoons i was
already experiencing and the
greenhouse gas emissions i was talking
about we needed
an organization that specifically talked
about the climate and so
me and my friends we decided to put up
youth advocates for climate action
philippines
i realized that i have no choice i have
to join the struggle of our
environmental defenders and of the
people for
a better planet a better future a safe
presence
i had to join the fight
that's it for today's show but you can
get your climate fix over the weekend
with our podcast
on this week's episode find out how a
little golden toad
led to the world's most important
climate treaty that's on climatecast and
you can find it wherever you normally
get your podcast from
and of course you can watch our weekly
digital show with ali fortescue on
sky new social channels our app and
website thanks for watching
and see you next week